in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jeremy
and Jennifer are with us hey how are ya
hi Dave how are you good to have you
guys let's honor to have you a couple of
gazelle t-shirts yes sir custom t-shirts
for the debt-free screen yes sir
and blue shirts and a blue boots to go
with it I mean you went all out kiddo I
did serious gazelle fashion statement
going here all right so what are you all
up Austin Texas
whoo and welcome to Nashville and here
to do a debt-free scream yes sir and how
much have you paid off $37,000 David
excellent and how long did that take 37
months that works that's easy math and
your range of income during that three
years so we started at about 65 got up
to 90 now we're at 105 after we got done
Wow excellent very good what do you guys
do for a living
I am a retail manager for a big install
men's clothing store okay and I'm a
customer service supervisor for HomeAway
oh very good good excellent so what kind
of debt was the 37,000 like most people
kind of a little bit of everything there
was some medical bills a couple of
credit cards cards student loans some
cars things like that what was the
biggest debt the cars the other cars
definitely what Joe in your cars when I
first bought mine was about $12,000 and
hers was about $8,000 brother so 20 of
the 37 give or take yeah all right
excellent good so tell me the story what
happened three years ago 37 months ago
well Dave a friend of mine gave me your
book the more than enough and I said we
don't really need this
I mean we're fine yeah well and we kind
of thought we were we had kind of been
doing something kinda like this for a
while before that we paid cash for our
wedding we were engaged for two years so
we could save up and didn't have to go
into our wedding with any denmoor the
day of the ceremony so it's you know
whatever we're fine so after the wedding
we started to fight about money I
realized that we might need a little bit
of help so a really good friend of mine
her name is Keeley and she's listening
watching now and she told me that the
best thing to do would be to go to FB
you and so we went that for you and when
we took that class it's actually kind of
cool the cup
that coordinated our class is right over
here next to us they came with us today
they were coming very cool which is a
great honor for them to be here because
they were in here from the beginning of
this journey they were instrumental in
helping us down the road on this journey
which was very difficult very cool so
what church was the class huh it was
originally a Bible Baptist Church at
Pflugerville Texas okay and we were
going there we actually started going to
that church after the class okay and
then we've actually moved to Wells
Branch Community Church where we're
gonna be teaching momentum in July Wow
good for you guys
good you just become straight-up poster
children for this whole thing she's
actually the the mod for a Facebook
group called gazelles
there are 291 people on that group with
293 counting us Oh until you said that
now you don't know what you're gonna get
right right yeah one of the things about
the gazelles the reason that we got so
excited about that we had the shirts
made is because your message about the
cheetah has resonated so hardcore with
me that the one out of nineteen chases
you got a run run run to get out of debt
and it just really resonated so Thursday
is cheetah killing Thursday okay show
the debt eradicate the debt build your
dreams live like no one else yeah there
you go
very cool I love it that's perfect well
done so so you got in the class and you
sat down and actually changed your whole
way of handling money and putting
together a budget now you're
coordinating classes and you know
running your own Facebook group and the
whole thing so when people ask what you
did to get out of debt what do you tell
them the key to being to becoming
debt-free is it was Co D which it
doesn't mean cash-on-delivery in this
case it's it's communication
organization and then dedication Oh
y'all practice that that was good yeah
we're actually a Toastmasters group back
home and I mean we gave a speech about
this right after we got out of debt so
so so now that I got past the fact that
it was all staged
tell me again what was it so it's
communication uh-huh organization and
then determination or dedication ya know
both work oh good you guys very well
done
okay so what was the biggest fight you
had while you were doing this so
she's pointing at him so one of the big
ones and it was actually little bit
before him was when we were getting
ready to get married and we were saving
up for that she had a budget here and I
had a budget like down here
and I was trying to get somewhere in the
middle there was a big one before the
before we got on the journey before we
got on the dream and then afterwards
well the bike was to get you to take a
few yes but then they offered dinner
every night and I went okay that's fine
it was funny yeah you bring food and
into the equation then ninety or a
hundred dollars ends up becoming ten or
nine dinners out yeah I'm fine with
spending a hundred hours for nine
dinners out and I hear this question on
your show a lot Dave because obviously
I've listened to you once or twice
mm-hmm the way to get him on board
because I know that people ask that
question all the time I think when I
took on three jobs and I got serious
about us paying off our debt he saw that
it was important to me yeah and so then
I worked two jobs for a while as well
and that was actually one of the hardest
things for us on this was there for a
while we really didn't get to see each
other very much because of the fact that
we were both working so much and so many
hours so now here you stand 37 months
later everything's paid off huh how's it
feel it feels great the the biggest
question we get now is people are asking
us if we're gonna stay out of debt
mm-hmm and a couple of people had some
smart remarks about we're honest debt
free roadtrip because we went to Florida
and Nashville and then st. Louis and
they said oh so you're gonna go back
into debt we said no no you didn't hear
the first part of our speech but now
they asked us if we're gonna stay stay
out of debt because we are actually 19
weeks expecting our first child will
congratulations thank you very fun so
they try to say well you can't say the
debt with a baby
you bet I can I could buy a lot of
diapers with the money that I'm not
spending on credit cards a man yeah I
mean you've been used to living on
$1,000 a month less I think you can make
it yeah very well done all right you
guys are fun very good job very good job
Jeremy and Jennifer Austin Texas a pair
of gazelles baby
that's right $37,000 paid off in 37
months making 65 to 105 count it down
let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
love it love it love
this is how it's done hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind